en france dix femmes responsables
politiques de droite comme de gauche ont
lancé dans l'hebdomadaire l'express un
manifeste des 10 pour la parité parité
homme-femme bien entendu dans la
politique il faut dire qu'il ya du pain
sur la planche
la france lanterne rouge de l'europe
compte seulement 5% de femmes au
parlement
j'ai vite en mer pas besoin d'être du
même bord politique pour s'entendre sur
des évidences la sous représentation des
femmes dans la vie publique ça suffit
elles sont de droite ou de gauche et
pousse aujourd'hui le même cri du coeur
échaudé par une longue expérience des
moeurs politiques
lorsque j'ai conduit des listes
européennes et que j'avais soi-disant au
moins à dire pour leur constitution
quand je demandais faut davantage de
femmes et on disait toujours ah bah non
celle ci à la chose c'est autre chose
donc ya beaucoup de femmes qui le
désirent et qui sont aujourd'hui tout à
fait dans la cape est dans
l'impossibilité de se présenter
la faute à qui ce sont bien les hommes
politiques qui sont sur la sellette
ils sont obsédés par le court terme donc
et par le garder à pouvoir le garder et
surtout ils sont fascinés par les sites
extérieurs avec 30 de femmes pour 577
députés la france est en effet bonne
dernière de toute l'europe elles sont
aujourd'hui moins de 6% dans l'hémicycle
qui a dit macho l'espagne compte plus
d'un député femme sur cinq
l'allemagne plus d'un quart la suède
près de la moitié au gouvernement quatre
femmes ont survécu au dernier
remaniement
il en va de même dans les grandes villes
dans les régions les hommes sont
quasiment seul aux commandes leur donc
est à l'action au manifeste elles sont
dix tout ancien ministre tout réclame la
méthode contraignante celle des quotas
une proportion obligatoire de candidates
aux élections et on est une société
figée bloqué à peu cassée donc c'est
peut-être un moyen de à des moyens avec
les femmes devront sans doute être
patient si alain juppé n'est sous un
référendum sur la question
jacques chirac 1976 aux partisans des
quotas
c'est d'abord aux mentalités d'évoluer
la loi floral offre
jouer avec